as far as your dancing was it makes me
think that you should be on Dancing with
the Stars like have you thought of that
have you been approached you're not a
fan of there to the stars for myself but
it's not the place it's not is it so
structured like is that not your dance
it's to volume for me like I get it it's
per certain people but I don't I love
the show I'm a huge fan of it but I
don't think I could do it just because
it's not my type of dance okay and I
don't think I'd be comfortable with it
just because it's too different for me
it's bro I say that now but we'll see
what happens but Dinah Jane is no
stranger to Dancing with the Stars in
2016 she lit up the stage with her fifth
harmony girl
[Applause]
[Music]
then she supported normanni as she
danced her way to the top as a runner-up
on season 24
[Music]
it's just already seems difficult
there's like a one to tango at their
salsa jazz I did jazz before I could do
jazz just I'm kind of worn to the swaggy
group that's where I'm at right yeah I
mean you know what you you know how to
do your thing stick me there I just
don't know how I would fit and like a
little corset with a skirt and a little
I like doing my pants on my shorts my
booty shorts right yeah so for now no
but for now maybe never said never and
never seen it it's a no for now on
competing for the Mirrorball trophy but
the bottled-up singer is hoping to land
one role after narrowly missing it the
first time I heard you were in the
running for Moana yes yes I was okay
tell me about that like how did the
audition go surprises like it was pretty
nerve-wracking I'm not gonna lie you
know the thing goes like my third round
they can we come in and then I had to
sing a song in my native language and
they were like can you sing us something
I did that part I knew I nailed that one
that was easy I was just delivering the
the script was kind of challenging just
because I felt like my boys had to sound
like a little girl yeah and I don't have
that I already sound like I'm and I'm
just really grateful for the experience
and it's got me excited for what's yet
to come and what else I wanted to go do
I just wanted to be you know the
Polynesian girl representing the
Polynesian princess which was Moana and
it was just really pretty exciting and
I'm just glad that that film was in the
first place created yeah because who
would have thought there'd be like a
Disney Princess and choose Polynesian if
they came out with a sequel would you
want to be a part of that I would love
to if anything I'd love to be a part of
the soundtrack so soundtrack I love the
sound check
[Music]
and Dwayne killed it on you're welcome
what can I say
girl he's the reason why I kind of went
an audition like he kind of encouraged
me to come out and try it out and his
daughter I'm a good friend friends with
her and Simone and she was pretty
excited because she's like you should
come out and represent so I did the best
that I could
okay the best I could and then there's
not the first and last Polynesian
princess movie that will come out or
opportunity for Dinah Janine exactly
[Music]